تركيا تكشف تفاصيل تفجير اسطنبول المتهمه
سوريه الجنسيه بعد انباء عن نقله الى
المستشفى لابروفلو بالشورت وينفي ماسك في
المحكمه للدفاع عن راتبه فيتاسله ب 52
مليار دولار في السنه هذه الاخبار وغيرها
انا نقولها لكم من قناه العربيه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
والبدايه من تركيا حيث فجر وزير الداخليه
التركيه سليمان صويلو مفاجاه عن المتهمه
بالضلوع في تفجير شارع الاستقلال في
اسطنبول رصدت فرق الامن اتصالات عقب
الانفجار مباشره تحمل تعليمات صريحه
بتصفيه هذه المتهمه وكانت سلطات التركيه
اعلنت عن اعتقال عشرات المتهمين بالتفجير
الذي اودى بحياتي سته اشخاص واكثر من 80
جريحا عقب فحصيلات
كاميرا كما كشفت شرطه اسطنبول عن هويه
المتهمه الرئيسيه مشيره الى انها امراه
سوريه
وتم تدريبها من قبل حزب العمال الكردستاني
ووحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه حسبما اعلنت
الشرطه التركيه
وفي ايران افضل القضاء حكما بالاعدام بحق
شخص على خلفيه اتهامات وجهه اليه من ضلوع
في اعمال شغب خلال الانتفاضه الشعبيه ضد
قمع قوه النظام ويعدها اول حكم بالاعدام
يعلنه النظام رسميا على خلفيه الاحتجاجات
الشعبيه التي تشهدها البلاد منذ قرابه
شهرين اثراء مقتل الشابه ماسا امينه ما
دفع منظمات المحليه ودوليه لادانه الحكم
في فيديو ظهر به وهو يرتدي شورت نفى وزير
الخارجيه روسيه رجال انباء نقله الى
المستشفى بعد وصوله الى اندونيسيا
للمشاركه في قمه مجموعه ال 20 هاجم
الصحفيين الغربيين ملتهما اياهم بالكذب
على مدى عشر سنوات عبر نشر تقارير عن مرض
الرئيس بوتين ووصفا انباء تعرضه لوعكه
صحيه في اندونيسيا باللعبه السياسيه وفي
وقت سابق نقلت اصل الشيكل بريس عن مسؤولين
اندونيسيين قولهم ان لافروف جرى علاجه من
مرض في القلب لكن وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
نفذ ذلك هو وصفتها بالتقارير الوهميه
نزل الملياردير الامريكيه الى الماسكي
يثير والجدل هذه المره بسبب راتبه في شركه
تسلا حيث ذكرت صحيفه وسط الامريكيه ان
ماسك سيتوجه الى المحكمه للدفاع عن راتبه
الذي يقدر بحوالي 52 مليار دولار في السنه
وكان احد المساهمين في شركه تسلا قدم طلبا
لمحكمه دلوير للاعمال من اجل الغاء حزمه
مرتب ماسك والتي تمت الموافقه عليها في
2018 زاعما ان مجلس اداره الشركات في ذلك
الوقت فاشله في الكشف عن المعلومات
الاساسيه حول المرتب وكيف يتم تجميعها
في خبرنا الاخير فتح النجم البرتغالي
كريستيانو رونالدو النار على نبيه الحليب
مانشستر يونايتد ومديره الفنيه
بسبب تعرضه للخيانه وفي مقابله اجرها مع
الاعلاميه البريطانيه الشهير بيرس مورجان
اعتبر رونالدو ان اداره النادي خانته
بمحاولته اجباره على الرحيل الصيف الماضي
مؤكدا انه لا يحترم لان الاخير لم يظهر له
الاحترام ايضا حسب تعبيره